now you've got a good idea of what
jQuery has to offer you've learned that
jQuery is just a JavaScript library and
it doesn't contain any hidden magic
you've learned how to easily select
anything in the Dom with jQuery you've
learned a few basic Dom access methods
and you've manipulated the Dom with ease
you've gone beyond that to add to and
remove from the DOM and you've even
learned how to use jQuery to simply
iterate through the Dom in a few lines
of code but best of all you've learned
how to read through jQuery documentation
and make sense of it all it's not some
big scary beast jQuery is a tamable
library with methods that are simple to
learn as they are to write you're ready
to get out there and start writing some
elegant concise front-end code with
jQuery but before I let you go there's
one more jQuery trick I want you to
learn in the very last part of the
lesson you'll find some written
instructions about one of the most
interesting features of jQuery which is
passing a function into the jQuery
object to run on document dot ready are
you feeling up for one last challenge